on va poursuivre avec mes collègues
gérard filion et sébastien bovet
sébastien je vais commencer avec vous le
volet politique qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière ce projet de loi spécial
comment est-ce qu'on justifie cela deux
mots emploi et gaspésie vous savez le
gouvernement a adopté depuis le début de
l'année un discours dans lequel il se
présente comme celui qui va relancer
l'économie or ils pensent que le projet
de port daniel va créer et maintenir des
emplois la question de savoir où en
gaspésie et la gaspésie sont actualisées
de la madeleine est une région au taux
de chômage frôle les 20%
c'est une région qui se vide de ses
jeunes qui a besoin de stimulation
économique
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement va présenter cette loi
donne un sens général c'est un bon plan
d'investissement pour le québec
écoutez le mot et le soin est important
500 millions de dollars investis en
capital par la famille beaudoin
bombardier la caisse de dépôt et
placement du québec investissement
québec et 600 millions de dollars auprès
d'un syndicat bancaire et
d'investissement québec dont il ya pas
de subvention est vraiment des
investissements là dedans
cette entreprise là l'objectif
d'exporter par la voie maritime ou du
béton et du ciment et de fer des projets
justement sur la côte est américaine à
la suite de l'ouragan samedi on veut
profiter de ces investissements là les
autres cimenteries qui sont ciment
québec
holcim lafarge canada et colas m canada
ne sont pas d'accord affirmant qu'en ce
moment l'utilisation de leurs capacités
de production est autour de 60 65 % mais
à terme ça pourrait devenir l' usine la
plus polluante du québec la plus
polluante le site le plus polluant du
québec quand on regarde des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre par site les sites
les plus polluants au québec en 2013
valero à lévis sont encore à montréal
alouettes à sept-îles rio tinto fer et
titane à sorel tracy
la cimenterie de port daniel gascons
dans le pire des scénarios émettrait un
million huit cent mille tonnes de co2
alors c'est important du point de vue
environnemental mais l'entreprise dit
qu'elle a réduit de 20 % l'intensité des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport à la moyenne des cimenteries
d'amérique du nord
n'empêche si bastien d'avoir obtenu la
caution des groupes environnementaux le
gouvernement a bien joué ses cartes
à terme stratégique c'est parfait à
partir du moment où les groupes
environnementaux accepte un processus de
médiation sur les litiges
environnementaux ils deviennent la
caution morale la caution
d'acceptabilité sociale du gouvernement
en termes stratégiques aussi peut-être
qu'on place le parti québécois dans
l'embarras
c'est lui qui a présenté le projet de
port daniel alors ils devraient voter en
principe en faveur du projet de loi pour
protéger ce projet là mais il ya quand
même un paradoxe et on a parlé en termes
environnemental pour un gouvernement qui
se présente comme le champion de la
lutte contre les gaz à effet de serre
d'avoir un projet aussi polluant ça peut
apparaître comme un paradoxe ce soit
quelqu'un au gouvernement me présenter
la décision comme une décision
pragmatique à cause des enjeux
économiques associés au projet
pragmatique intéressant merci au revoir